right before Christmas a good guy in red
is coming to theaters with his new
sidekick
Fred why am I here you're in a pg-13
version of Deadpool filtered through the
prison of childlike innocence and nobody
does childlike innocence like you Fred
nobody I need you almost as much as you
need me I don't need you at all me to
untie you once we're done
[Music]
I loved your working up I'm sorry
don't get to a test once upon a Deadpool
character for Marvel movies we are
Merkel yeah but you're you know Marvel
license my Fox it's like if the Beatles
were produced by Nickelback its music
but it sucks you were nicer as a kid
rated pg-13 limited engagement in
theaters December close ok so we have
our first official trailer for Once Upon
a Deadpool if you haven't been keeping
up this is a pg-13 version of Deadpool
too but there's going to be an
additional 15 minutes of new footage in
the movie including this first scene
that we got here why am I here
you're in a pg-13 version of Deadpool so
the first scene starts off with Deadpool
and Fred Savage
fred is mostly known for his childhood
role on the show The Wonder Years and
Deadpool has kidnapped him so of course
he's asking why is there and Deadpool
makes a joke that he's going to need him
to untie him because Deadpool has
kidnapped him when Ryan Reynolds agreed
to have a pg-13 version of Deadpool 2 he
said he'd do it under two conditions one
is that some of the money from the
ticket sales would go to charity and two
he'd get to kidnap Fred Savage in the
movie I don't really think that this is
going to be really a part of the story
and once upon a Deadpool but what I
really think is going to happen is
basically Deadpool is going to be
reading the story to Fred Savage as we
watch it only a few more new scenes in
this trailer but they are pretty funny
we have this scene where Deadpool is
sitting on a park bench with an elderly
couple
the woman is holding balloons so they
look like the couple from up so Deadpool
says I loved your work and up but of
course she actually ends up dying in the
movie so he tells the man not to get too
attached
just typical Deadpool slash Ryan
Reynolds humor and then of course we
have this hilarious scene at the end
where Fred Savage says I kind of prefer
Marvel movies and Deadpool says we are
Marvel Fred Savage makes the joke that
yeah you're not really Marvel you're
Marvel licensed by Fox you're not in the
MCU basically saying that since he's not
really Marvel he sucks in which of
course it offends Deadpool but this is
just typical Deadpool humor that I love
from all the movies you know
Marvel license by Fox it's like if the
Beatles were produced by Nickelback it's
music but it sucks you were nicer as a
kid and it's finally a great opportunity
for the younger viewers who can't see
rated our movies to go out and see a
Deadpool movie and again it's for
charity so it's for a really good cause
remember it comes out December 12th and
will only be in theaters for 12 days so
be sure to go see it while you get a
chance and I'm still doing my giveaway
giving away a copy of the Avengers art
of the movie art book a copy of infinity
war Deadpool 2 or ant-man and the wasp
and some special edition posters all you
have to do for your chance to win is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]